les serial et on va que yazid est acide
qui va nous faire sur des brides hier et
il a des choses à dire moyens cités par
[Applaudissements]
je ne veux pas c'est que des gens comme
ça sarah castaldi et oui mais qui à vu
d'oeil période qui a fait une voix très
bon dans la période étendue mesdames et
messieurs une pandémie mondiale le
confinement le chômage à effets divers
mets toi cyril mon frère vu que tu es un
génie hier tu démarres l'émission avec
un débat qui nous rappelle le sens des
priorités des tudors toi je déteste le
pyjama le slip j'aime pas du tout non
j'aime bien d'un père nu mais elle fait
peur qui est des trucs qui rentrent en
vous maintenant date en date au risque
s'est avéré qu'ils ont déjà remis deux
fois l'om slip ben moi oui des fois je
mets pas tout bêtement fumée jing
surnommé le djing de poids dessus away
pas devant vous sur des styles tous les
jours oui normalement oui ça m'est
jamais arrivé voilà donc moi je m'étais
de la veille voilà des choses qu'on
n'aimerait pas savoir donc n'hésitez pas
à rire à réagir h taxe lipides et le
pire c'est que tous les lits s'y trouve
ça normal comme débat et cyril demande
pas si vite et si mais des slips à 19h27
frère c'est trop tôt ça c'est des
questions de 23h minuit en plus regarder
comment ça s'est fini par dire oui quand
vous dormez pas chez vous par exemple si
vous avez une absence où ils sont logés
ont été bonnes cibles se sent pas du
tout
voilà votre smic
je le sens pas d'accord je pense que
cette phrase va entrer dans l'histoire
la preuve je vous adaptez votre cible ce
sont pas du tout alors vous avez aussi
parlé de rémy d'ail et ont préféré ras
el mellah l'ancien chef du modem à
toulouse qui est devenu gourou
conspirationnistes kidnappeurs d'enfants
cgem bollocks écouter ce qu'il dit qui
me mettre à fleury mérogis j'écrirai mon
livre là ce sera l'occasion les gens
cesseront de dire que je suis du système
ce seront des dire que je suis planqué
ils verront que je suis en première
ligne et je pourrai de la forme en t la
contre révolution nécessaire dans ce
pays ça va encore beaucoup plus de bruit
et je suis sûr que j'aurai plein de gens
plein d'amis chez les matons chez les
politiciens jardin j'en suis convaincu
mais tais toi là mettez moi en prison
pour que je prépare la révolution on
dire une phrase de rohff j'suis en
malaisie mais ma chère géraldine se
trouve qu'il aima les ans
[Applaudissements]
quand j'ai vu qu'il a ce jeu de mots il
dit que la malaisie était un pays plus
tolérants clubs français c'est vrai la
preuve avec ces chiffres
voilà 1280 condamné à mort en 2019 en
malaisie selon amnesty international
bonnes vacances rémy déjà
heureusement pour lui qui s'appelle rémy
parce que si ça plaît amenez des abdel
je peux te dire qu'on sera les chercher
par le slip n'est ce pas steve rémi die
est encore un homme qui veut faire la
révolution alors le problème
la révolution c'est comme le sport on a
envie mais on n'y va jamais faut arrêter
de critiquer la france moi je te dis la
vérité parce que faut arrêter de dire
que c'est un pays de merde la france est
comme un fromage
des fois ça pue nous on aime bien
l'odeur enfin le dernier débat détendue
du site il y at-il assez de blancs dans
certains quartiers en france où saute il
réintroduire les blancs comme les ours
dans les pyrénées
voilà pourquoi mais battue a invité un
mec de cité regarder j'étais au 140 rue
ménilmontant c'est à dire c'était une
semaine à la cité la pire du quartier
d'accord la pierre de cet endroit tu
collectionnes sang comme on l'entend
voilà son rôle août ces mecs de quartier
a toujours dédicacer leurs cartes
un guillaume bigot ses rires quand j'ai
vu le débat hier je me suis dit pourquoi
aller sur mars frères pourquoi aller
déranger une planète paisible où tout se
passe bien il lui a porté des débats
comme j'habite 240 voix la syrie tu a
invité aussi une féministe identitaire
alice elle a 23 ans
l'autre fois tu avais invité thaïs qui à
21 ans mais n'ont pas compte de bio déjà
celle là la raison pas un exposé à
rentrer sur charlotte charlemagne au
lieu de mal parler des banlieues au
racisme frère je te le dis faut inviter
des gens qui ont de la bouteille
toi tu les prends cm2 et puis il faut
des gens cultivés pas des gens qui
disent ah ça parlait à l'issue une fois
tranquillement a dit qu'est ce que vient
de dire là au luxe qu'est ce que vous
dites sur l'équipe de france sur
laquelle a été racheté en grande partie
par le qatar donc si c'est cette coupe
de france
voilà bah allez pas très foot n'est pas
très franc batterie de court alors
l'équipe de france c'est simple et les
commentaires de votre émission moral à
l'équipe de france appartient à la
france le psg à partir au qatar par
contre après ce que tu as dit majeur
j'ai entendu l'émir du qatar qui voulait
racheter alice et de mettre dans les
buts du psg rien pour gaulle rioual à
titus et il ya des gens quand ils sont à
l'élastique
il se pose la question est ce que je
saute toi tu sautes sans élastique
tu as invité brute nixon de flux'
rappeur respecté et respectable qui
était face à guillaume bigot
alors pour moi bigot contre brute luxe
et pas un débat frère c'est de l'art
contemporain jeu en plus il parle comme
un joueur de foot en première attention
regardez lomax a fait le tour du monde
de relais qu 6 et trucks en pis taxe max
and roll en 4 4 y'a pas de trucs comme
ça
victor valdes ou c'est que vous n'avez
pas pu c'est lui qui une star
internationale avec lebron jeter que la
couronne vous salue madame un star
internationale et belleville est mon ami
mais vous commencez alors on peut venir
de belleville est rachat d'or belleville
et j'habite au 54 asie elle habite au 56
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
n'appuyez pas là aujourd'hui puisqu'il
en arrêt maladie rappelle que cyril est
le seul qui veut réconcilier l'eau et le
feu pour finir en ce moment j'entends
souvent parler du grand remplacement à
propos des musulmans
j'ai donc décidé de vous présenter ce
soir les grands remplaçant
[Musique]
bonjour vingtaine michel et je suis
cadre tirs bonjour moi c'est ses coups
et je le grand vincent michel bonjour je
m'appelle hervé et ma fille a quitté
christophe pour un certain ording
bonjour si nordine et je suis le grand
repas saint-christophe si vous aussi
vous voulez rejoindre les rangs passant
écrivent et nos 22 impasse eric zemmour
fachos cedex alors alors ça se sent dans
la question les musulmans vont-ils
remplacer les autres je réponds non la
preuve par un truc qu'on réinvente et
les arabes les maths
s'il ya 65 millions de français dont 6,5
millions de musulmans sur une échelle de
70 ans
combien de temps faudra-t-il pour
remplacer tous les français sept cents
ans donc dormez tranquilles la terre
aura explosé d'ici là mais il y aura
toujours des pnp bonne santé